olá a todos sua alta aqui quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo já mais um
vídeo e o estrago de que faz nights é
fredes dois eu estou aqui trazer pessoal
o segundo vídeo do dia eu já fiz a
primeira noite está em baixo na
descrição passa por lá pessoal vejam
este vídeo e depois voltem pra este caso
estejam a ver este vídeo depois do outro
estiveram em ver este vídeo antes do
outro é muito confuso mas é pessoal isso
vai ser um vídeo do dia porque vocês
deram um apoio gigantesco no primeiro
vídeo então é por isso que eu estou
agora a trazer estes com vida mas não
nos deixava comércios não vivemos aqui
chegar à segunda noite desta segunda
noite pessoal vai ser mais assustador
porque há cinco fazendas e prédios
funciona não é quanto quanto mais
prolongado a noite mais difícil é louco
se mais difícil é mais assustador é esse
majestoso é mas é coisa boa e vamos lá
jogar o pessoal aqui muitas vozes dizem
para eu ouvir a kyoto phone mas eu não
quero ouvir não quer ouvir das pistas
dele eu simplesmente quer jogar em
buraco é é só isso que eu quero lá ok eu
sou aqui parados o que é bom e eu já tô
usuário somente agora com seu jato suar
não
já tô só por todos os lados mesmo caiu
palhaço natal para sakineh é que tal
pagar só que eu tenho que ter muita
atenção esta caixa eu já sei disso
porque se não tiver atenção a esta casa
o palhaço salta para cima porque você já
comentaram no vídeo anterior que se não
controlar bem esta caixa o palhaço vai
voltar a seguir não quero falar não só
pra cima e aos a tapa e ir outra vez que
eu que comecei aqui na caixa
já ciro mas daqui só sejam dois daqui se
usa pediu o sequestro do meu carro você
não possa já não estava aqui tá josé
coelho meu ok go não é causar pinto o zé
pinto é pinto neto tadeu pinto quer
dizer que ele está aqui um detalhe
apimenta a calma ter o palhaço mil
ainda lá não posso deixar que espalhar
sair daqui anda anda anda anda com os
outros não têm outro piloto
eu quero você pinto meu desapareceu e
não seja onde quem manda
o gato taques é com ela que o setentão
servindo o fred já sinto bem também e
agora é de agora
acho que vamos saltar em cima da pedra e
não conseguisse dinheiro do jogador é o
coelho foi para ali né não um de cantar
josé palhares tav também você pegar a
chave também com a marca lá eu não sei
da caixa ainda tirou a raposa assumiu no
fim não está aqui
vamos lá então tentar outra vez agora
com mais cuidado pessoal e eu tenho que
estar mais atento é que a câmera então
do palhaço por culpa dela se extrai
muito quando vocês vão lavar a caixa os
outros terminais e parece ser mesmo que
eu não chamo vocês têm que ir lá pro
para a caixa porque não é é quando
aquela pizza e você já perto os outros
aparecem e não convém isso acontecer
precisamos espera não é e é pronto e já
não tá ela chamar meu tempo ter muito
cuidado com esse palhaço cocaína lá no
estudo é sean está ok agora tentará
tentei janete
enquanto eu estiver aqui acho que nada
vai acontecer
eu acho que está tudo vazio que o
pessoal e nenhum e josé coelho não não
prova nada estava a brincar amigo está a
brincar ok não vai aparecer aqui não vai
então jj e outros nem tão que os de
palhaço é palhaço tentar acordar ser
palhaço que ouvir e ouvir a voz de uma
menina meu
vou falar comigo olá lá você colhe o
cantor está aqui meu não sai daqui meu
nego gestão 11 josé pinto também já
apareceu de repente desapareceu
josé pinto agora é pintou na nossa
equipe está aqui porque eu sei o que se
procura é mais que meu você pinta
amarela aqui calma alguém na ventilação
o boneco o boneco também se mexe
calma calma calma desculpas com o boneco
é um palhaço também tav não não foi
assim também com a vida calma não tem
nem o que é e vamos tentar mais uma vez
pessoal passar aqui segunda noite mas
estas condenou 80 efectivamente muito
mais difícil do que a primeira mão é
muito mais bacana de palhaço
taques é palhaça ela voltará a corda do
ipmet chamar por mim lá isso o chamamé
estoque total caiu agora voltou a
controlar o palhaço e este age eu não
sei ser o suposto e controlar é que este
boneco também desculpa porque ela
parecia uma lei da época e vocês viram
que o nec também se mexe e agora nós
temos muito mais anima tronics atrás nós
as coisas mais complicadas não é nada
nem nas do balão se usa do balão do
balão total 101 estão inclusas
eu estava aqui do méxico
i o seu fato final é que o lugar foi
cama como se pegasse itápolis
você pode até pedir ajuda de mãe os
raposas vai saltar em cima de mim eu
sair você pareceu da wii doc filho da
mãe como é um desafio agora como como
explica porque está segura junto e que
só hoje ontem
como é que um software que usar o fred é
apontado eu sou eu
vamos certamente não falou quando ainda
era menina e nem sinal
calma calma pessoal néné está a ficar
muito entre um sul
assim não gosto da briosa palhaço lá
anda um pouquinho agora como é isso
possível passar isso além do possível
então é isso pessoal nós vamos ficar
porque com esta segunda noite desta
segunda à noite está muito mais difícil
em comparação à primeira e eu ainda
tenho de treinar muito mais para
conseguir passar lá mas é isso aí nós
vamos ficar porque com este vídeo espero
que vocês gostem esclarecidos com um
vídeo do dia só porque vocês apoiaram
mesmo muito primeiro é e merecem claro
merecem estão a apoiar merece mais
vídeos
é esse pessoal espero que vocês gostem
fique bem e até a próxima